we get to say congratulations on your  new home you bought it from the  legendary Genevieve era who we all loved  here especially here at ET so and we  know that you wrote a letter to her  family yeah I mean it's obviously it was  a very very special home to them and for  them to part with it I can only imagine  was a very emotional process and so you  know we just wanted to make it clear  that it's it's a special home to us as  well and and all the all the great kind  of memories that they have we hope to  create our own memories in there are so  we just wanted to write a kind of  personal a lot of times when you buy a  house it's just a business thing but  houses you know they're they're chapters  of our lives that that we want to  remember fondly and we just wanted to  make it clear to them that we respected  the house and respected them and kind of  carry on their their love  you